how's it going guys matt here code tech
notorious and i want to show you
just a simple thing about c plus plus
programming and uh well let me just jump
into the backstory i've always wanted to
be able to just launch my terminal and
type in a function
or type in something and just have it do
exactly what i want yeah that's simple
and in this example i'm going to say
randomizer i've always wanted to just be
able to randomize things on the fly
without having to launch an application
and go through a bunch of steps of going
through a
tool just right here in the command line
type it and type what you want roll 1d6
and it just does it and i want to be
able to run this from anywhere any
terminal no matter what i'm doing no
matter what drive i go to let's not go
to recycling bin
which is where some people think my
videos should go so we go to my e drive
i'm in my e drive but i can still just
run this whenever i want all right so if
you already know how to do this sweet
but how do you do it with c plus plus
program and uh any way you want well i'm
going to show you we're going to walk
through how to build this randomizer in
c plus plus and uh install it on your
computer basically so that you can run
it from your command line this works
essentially the same for linux except
the place yeah well i'll mention that
when we get to it but it's mostly the
same and uh you can put other things in
here too and if you can program it
however you want we can say what about
uh can we do this syntax roll 1d6
sure we'll allow that and we put other
stuff in here too like percent like
percentage chance or dash p
maybe we can put a help menu in case
they don't type the right stuff and uh
there it is so yeah just a little
command line tool a randomizer let's
walk through how to build it alrighty
and here is the most important step
don't don't build it just clone this hit
run and hit install and then adjust your
path so that this randomizer exe is
somewhere in your path how do you do
that oh you just go to you just type in
path here in windows and you want to
edit your system environment variables
and linux is different it's like a dot
bash rc file or something you'll have to
google it i don't know off top of my
head but it's essentially where you do
this sort of thing so we go here to
uh environment variables this is system
properties advanced environment
variables and what we want to do here is
edit the path now we have two places we
can do this we can use right here user
variables for says the username who's
logged in so you can set them for each
user or you can set them for every user
with system variables there's path right
here so you can do either if you want
everybody that uses this computer to be
able to do the thing uh do the do the
path for the system variables you just
want for your account you do it for user
variables simple enough we're going to
edit the system ones in this case and
you'll see there's a bunch of paths
already now all these paths are places
where stuff can run from your terminal
basically
so you'll see i have a bunch of
development stuff in here and a lot of
these are default now you can see just
the c drive is here so i guess anything
you put on your c drive is in your path
uh but i also put uh randomizer right
here at the bottom and this is just uh
the path to the source so it's basically
installed in the same place it builds
but i could you know you could move it
to some other directory that already has
it in the path because as you'll see
when we build this randomizer
uh let's just do it actually let's do it
so we've opened visual studio 2022 we're
on the c plus plus development uh cycle
we've also got the cmake tools installed
because this is a cmake project so
randomizer here it is we'll just open it
up i didn't do really anything super
special with the cmake i pretty much use
the default we got a top level one all
it does is add subdirectory basically
and the project uh subdirectory has the
one that uh sets up the executable for
randomizer and it's gotta install
target's just the executable so if we
install this by switching uh this target
thing to install and then release boom
that's the path we added that's the one
where we use anytime we open up a
terminal you can do this for any program
however it gets a little more
complicated when your program has
resources it needs like you know sound
files whatnot whatever you're using but
this has none because it's just command
line so
super easy but now you do this sort of
thing get the program built add it to
your path now you can just on your
windows computer do whatever you want
and have whatever program little
function helper stuff going on in your
terminal that you want they're very easy
to build they're very quick to build
just thought i'd show that i thought it
was a cool little beginner thing you
could do on your computer that anyone
could do technically without a ton of
knowledge and it's it's super useful you
can just build so much i mean this is
only the tip of the iceberg if you think
about it you could literally build like
game launchers and uh media players you
can process in whatever type of data you
want through these input arguments
because this could be a path to a file
stuff like that you get the point but uh
this is kind of the bread and butter of
c plus plus programming in general
because this is like where it all starts
it just you know just runs processes on
your computer that's it for this video
thanks for watching hope you got
something out of it and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
all right so how do you build this let's
walk through that real quick obviously
not gonna i'm not gonna type it up and
rebuild it i'm just gonna give you the
general steps so
uh when you start a new project here
visual studio you just do the see the
cmake template default and it's going to
give you most of the stuff you're going
to have to add these source files over
here as you add them it's going to it's
going to do the thing set them up for
your executable and you'll start with a
main you got to decide what you want to
do so we're taking in arguments and
we're taking in specifically two so i
have a little uh setup here well first
we start with a return result uh that
just
just in case we need it basically but if
we're not passing at least three
arguments we just display the help and
do nothing because it's wrong this only
takes two arguments the way it's made uh
your program may vary of course
obviously so the other case else if
there is exactly three arguments we
attempt to process set arguments to see
if we got a correct command and whatever
this all large returns is actually going
to be a 64-bit or a yeah 64-bit float or
double so we're going to turn that into
an int for the sake of the return value
for this main however this could be
pretty complicated because we're
basically doing a lot of percent chance
type things potentially so those are
often better as a big old float rather
than a hint
so
uh i did make a types file and the only
thing it has in is uh f64 is typed to a
double but uh yeah we just basically go
to process all arbs and that's just a
function we have here in this namespace
process uh all larps it just takes in
those args so we only call this if
there's a valid number and basically
this goes through and checks what we're
doing uh well it kind of processes your
args by doing a few helper things like
it removes white space from each other
and then it also makes everything lower
case so basically does not care about
caps and i felt like this removed white
space was helpful because there were
some cases where for some reason
characters would no matter what have a
space after them it's some white
character type thing that window does
and that turns into white space
sometimes so that's why this remove
white space is here but it's not really
not going to hurt anything uh the only
valid commands on this program have no
white space in the command so we always
want it in general uh but that's just
for this one so a little processing on
the args will pre-processing to help us
read them and you can see we've also
temporarily instantiated a command list
here this command list is basically the
valid commands that this takes we've got
that defined uh somewhere
maybe in the dot h out the dot h here it
is just a new num class there's invalid
roll dice percentage chance odds chance
that's the only valid things we could
simplify that you could only do one
thing i don't know whatever you want to
do but uh basically we're checking the
first command see if it matches any of
the said words and we turn it into the
correct command and uh then we switch on
the command because the command gets set
and it processes command now uh if it
was invalid we just display the args and
the help that you know they gave us
that's defined in these display classes
we'll show them real quick they're
pretty straightforward not going to talk
about them so you can pause if you need
those speaking of i should probably zoom
this in huh but uh yeah it just displays
stuff basically that's all it does i
just wanted to separate out the iostream
class and otherwise it processes a
command when it processes any of these
three valid commands it does the same
thing it gets the second variable uh rv2
that you passed in removes the white
space and then changes those all to
lower case same same little string
process you can do on the second
argument this one was only on the first
argument part v1 there well i say first
but really
the very first one is the zero spot and
we're skipping over that because it's
just the program name uh anyway so we go
to process follow-up now process
follow-up is helper function that is
private to this process so it's defined
up here it basically takes in the
command because we want to know what
type of command we're processing and
then the next arc and it attempts to do
the same so when it attempts to do the
thing it just switches on the command
type goes the right one say it's on roll
dice it's on roll dice it attempts this
if it's on percentage chance it attempts
this and you can see what it does
basically this just uh does some careful
string processing because this next r
should be like a number a d and then
another number so basically it looks for
it tries to get the first number just
first thing then it looks for the letter
a lowercase d and uh then if that's
successful it looks for the next number
after that process is it so it should
get like a number d 100 it's kind of
complicated because of how you have to
do this h is digit how you uh get the
pause basically you're getting the
position of the string i don't want to
get into that too much put a lot of
stack overflow posts on such a thing and
cbp reference if you're not real sure
how these work but basically we have the
process string and it's the same for all
these they're just a little different
because this one looks for a number then
a d then 100 then another number
percentage chance or uh yeah percentage
chance doesn't look for that just looks
for a number because you want us you
basically do a percent out of 100 so you
feed in a number between zero and 100
and it tells you if you happen to be
successful and all not your chance
that's all it does very simple odds
chance this is like if you want to feed
it like one in one million or something
this is for that so you can process
anything you can say okay the dentist
says i have a six and ten chance what is
that well it's obviously sixty percent
but maybe they give you a more
complicated number someone gives you a
more complicated number like you have a
62 and 104 chance or something or 64 and
some weird number this just processes
that turns it into a percent and says
whether you were successful or not not
so just another little odd feature but
essentially they all do something
similar with the uh string processing
and then doing the rand now the rand
this is uh something i wrote a long time
ago we're only using n to r random i
think what am i saying that's going to
make no sense to you guys so these
random functions are just functions
built on chrono and random see yeah
random chrono and all they do is they
seed based on the current world clock so
it's different every run so random seeds
on time basically it uses the merson
twister algorithm of that seed and uh
just feed you stuff
so these are the random functions i
think we're only using this one and this
one
there's just a bunch of extra i put
these a long time ago and i've just
always saved them so anytime i need them
i copy paste them in but they have weird
names uh the names are like uh this
doesn't really matter for the program
you can name something else but into
this is like n to k random that's what
it's supposed to stand for like uh so
it's just supposed to give you an idea
of what to pass in another indicate
random this one's float this one's end
you can't template all these as you
would expect because of the way you have
to instantiate different seed types i
think anyway and the way i'm doing them
static would probably mess that up too
but basically it's static so that it
doesn't keep reseeding like once you get
a seed you keep using that same one and
iterate through it through this mersenne
twister thing or at least that's my
understanding of it and that's about it
for the program let's see there is a
string util i think i just put the
remove white space function here because
it's being used in several files so i
wanted to separate it out the lowercase
one could be put in here too but it's
only used in one file that's why it's
not separated out that's the whole
program yeah once we run this install it
puts it in that directory uh that's just
a sample run there but yeah this is
where you get your debugger and all that
whatever you need